...
-Laure Heinich, vous refusez
d'être assignée à un camp.
Depuis quelques années,
vous vous battez
pour que les violences
faites aux femmes soient reconnues,
et si possible, condamnées.
-Oui, c'est un métier, avocat,
qui suit le mouvement de la société.
MeToo est un mouvement
qui a emporté
et qui continue
d'emporter la société.
Je crois que...
c'est l'apanage de l'avocat,
d'être aux côtés de ceux ou celles,
en l'occurrence, celles,
qui se battent, et donc...
le cabinet s'est aussi rempli
de femmes,
qui sont venues toquer à la porte.
-Votre cabinet
est 100 % féminin,
un quatuor d'associées,
ex-secrétaires
de la Conférence du stage,
la crème de la crème du barreau.
C'est le fruit du hasard ou...
cette sororité est délibérée,
revendiquée ?
C'est un parti pris ?
-Peut-être qu'aujourd'hui,
on le revendique.
Pas sûre
que ça se soit construit comme ça,
mais peut-être aussi.
C'est une amitié très forte.
On s'est retrouvées
autour de l'éloquence,
des combats,
de ce concours de la Conférence
du stage gagné ensemble.
Et ensuite, on...
s'est associées avec ces valeurs.
Je suis pas sûre d'aimer ce mot.
-C'est un joli mot, "valeurs".
-Peut-être.
Tous ces combats qui nous forment,
et qui nous sont communs,
et aujourd'hui,
on se pose la question :
est-ce que
c'est parce qu'on est des femmes
que ces combats sont communs ?
Pas sûre,
mais c'est joli de le dire.
-Gisèle Halimi et Françoise Cotta
ont été des mentors ?
-Absolument.
-Ces deux femmes.
-Ca fait plaisir, vraiment,
de les voir côte à côte.
Oui, des mentors.
Gisèle Halimi,
je me souviens d'avoir lu un livre,
j'étais vraiment jeune,
Djamila Boupacha...
qui était militante
au moment de la guerre d'Algérie,
que Gisèle avait défendue.
Quand je suis devenue avocate,
c'était la seule image de femme.
-Figure totémique.
-Il n'y avait qu'elle.
Je lui avais écrit
un CV, deux,
un nombre de lettres pas possible.
J'ai fini par faire ma carrière,
m'installer,
et un jour, elle m'a appelée
pour travailler,
partager des dossiers.
Des moments partagés formidables.
C'était une grande intellectuelle,
une penseuse, ce qu'on n'a pas
toujours chez les avocats.
On est travailleurs, militants,
quelque chose avec du corps,
peut-être moins avec l'intellect.
Une rencontre magnifique.
Françoise Cotta,
je l'ai rencontrée plus jeune.
Prof de tennis, je me voyais
lever la coupe à Roland-Garros.
Quand j'ai entendu plaider Françoise
à la cour d'assises,
je me suis dit :
"C'est mon endroit."
Ca a été une bascule.
-Vous le disiez,
la cause des femmes
est devenue un combat
à part entière de votre cabinet
et vous assistez
victimes et coupables,
aussi bien un ex-patron
accusé de viol, que des femmes
qui incriminent Georges Tron,
Jean-Jacques Bourdin ou PPDA.
Face à la pénaliste
Jacqueline Laffont,
vous ne tarissez pas d'éloges.
C'est fair-play.
En quoi avoir une adversaire
de cette qualité
est une chance ?
-Quand on a
un très bon avocat en face,
c'est une chance :
le débat est élevé,
il n'y a pas de coups bas.
Il n'y a pas d'insultes,
il y a du respect...
mutuel.
Alors, bien sûr,
on va s'affronter,
c'est possible aussi qu'à la sortie
de la salle d'audience,
on mette quelques semaines
à se reparler,
parce que ça peut être violent.
La violence du débat est là.
Mais la violence, parfois,
dans le débat judiciaire, reste
avec un respect mutuel très fort.
Je respecte le travail
de Jacqueline Laffont,
même si,
si vous voulez...
pour une plaignante,
entendre un avocat en face,
c'est une violence.
Que les plaignantes que j'assiste
ne supportent pas Jacqueline,
je le comprends.
Ca reste une chance
par rapport à des confrères
qui sont dans quelque chose
qui est plus personnel,
loin de la loi.
-L'une des accusatrices de PPDA,
Hélène Devynck, dit avoir collecté
plus de 90 témoignages
contre l'ex-star du 20h.
La plupart des faits présumés
sont prescrits.
16 plaintes, dont 8 pour viol,
ont été déposées
et classées sans suite.
Une information judiciaire
est en cours à Nanterre.
Les juges pourraient analyser
ces accusations dans l'ensemble,
plus de façon isolée.
En quoi l'approche
pourrait changer
radicalement la donne ?
-Je suis pas sûre que...
on en soit à ce que ça change
radicalement la donne.
Ce qui est réexaminé,
c'est vraiment le cas de...
Mme Porcel, qui elle,
a un viol non prescrit,
et un viol prescrit et c'est..
dans cet ensemble-là,
pour ce qui la concerne elle,
que les choses seront revues.
Ensuite, pour le moment,
les plaignantes qui sont prescrites
le demeurent, et c'est vrai
que c'est assez violent,
d'être le témoin de son viol
et en même temps, il y a aussi...
quelque chose de très beau,
à venir se dire :
"Je vais devant la justice,
je suis prescrite,
"mais je raconte mon histoire
et dis ce qui est arrivé."
La prescription reste acquise.
-La pénaliste Marie Dosé,
comme l'historienne
Elisabeth Badinter,
s'inquiète
de ces prescriptions glissantes,
qui assimileraient
des crimes individuels
à un crime contre l'humanité,
à les mettre sur le même plan.
Vous avez une dissonance
avec Hélène Devynck ?
Vous tenez à la prescription ?
-Je tiens au maintien
de la prescription.
C'est pas un crime
qui doit être imprescriptible.
Il n'y en a qu'un,
le crime contre l'humanité.
Mais je suis pas inquiète, moi,
de la dérive de la loi.
C'est peut-être la dissonance
que j'ai avec Marie Dosé :
je suis pas...
Je pense que la loi,
actuellement, c'est une bonne loi,
mais on doit pas aller plus loin.
Nous avons un crime, de masse,
collectif,
qui englobe le viol, d'ailleurs.
Moi, je défends
des plaignantes Tutsi,
qui ont été victimes de viols,
dans le cadre du génocide
contre les Tutsi.
Là, le crime de viol est reconnu
comme un crime contre l'humanité.
-Bien sûr.
-Il est imprescriptible.
Et je crois que...
qu'on doit rester comme ça.
C'est aussi la paix sociale,
et nous avons certaines plaignantes
qui vivent comme un soulagement
le fait que la prescription
soit acquise.
Il faut l'entendre.
-Elisabeth Badinter
s'est inquiétée
qu'on jette à la vindicte publique
un homme, en l'occurrence,
Julien Bayou, accusé de violences
psychologiques,
sans passer par la justice.
Ecoutons-la.
*-Où on est ?
Où sommes-nous...
pour mépriser à ce point
la justice ?
Je suis parfaitement en accord
avec le ministre de la Justice
et ses déclarations d'hier.
On peut pas...
à ce point mépriser
les principes démocratiques.
*-Eric Dupond-Moretti a dit :
"Fin de la récréation.
"C'est très dangereux :
"certains se font dévorer
par un monstre
"qu'ils ont contribué à créer.
"Les réseaux ne peuvent pas
être le réceptacle
"de la parole.
La justice doit intervenir.
"Nous allons arriver
vers une société de la délation.
"Mme Rousseau n'est pas
procureure de la nation."
*-Ce que reprochent,
et je peux le comprendre,
les féministes de MeToo
à la justice
et raisons pour lesquelles
elles leur tournent le dos,
c'est la prescription.
Quand c'est prescrit,
donc, il n'y a pas d'enquête...
policière et des juges.
Non, non, non, non.
C'est la fin, je dirais,
de la présomption d'innocence
et d'un travail sérieux.
On n'est pas...
On peut s'interroger.
Pourquoi on ne porterait pas plainte
avant la prescription ?
Enfin, je veux dire...
"Vous pouvez pas."
-Parfois,
les femmes se taisent.
-Pardon ? Il faut aussi
prendre ses responsabilités.
Je comprends
que pendant un certain temps,
même des années,
ça soit impossible à évoquer,
mais quand même, 10 ans...
-Je vous vois sourire.
-Ben oui, bon...
Le sourire, c'est un rempart
contre la violence.
Vous voyez...
quelle violence, là,
chez Elisabeth Badinter ?
-Que répondez-vous
à ceux qui s'inquiètent
de l'émergence
d'une société de l'inquisition ?
-Non, mais si vous voulez
siffler la fin de la récré,
c'est Eric Dupond-Moretti
qui dit ça,
qui est dans la cour de récré ?
Qui pense récréatif, en fait,
de se plaindre d'un viol,
et d'aller dénoncer un viol ?
Il faut qu'on soit vigilants,
que tout soit pas réglé
par les médias,
que l'enquête médiatique
ne supplée pas la judiciaire,
mais personne ne veut ça.
Hélène Devynck,
la première chose
qu'elle a faite,
c'est déposer une plainte,
même prescrite :
c'est là que le débat judiciaire
ou que l'enquête se fait.
Où est la difficulté ? D'aller dire
les choses sur le plan public.
Dans cette affaire,
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor est venu
sur un plateau dire :
"Qu'elles viennent me le dire,
les yeux dans les yeux."
Qu'il y ait une vigilance,
je suis d'accord,
qu'on dise que Mme Rousseau
aurait dû prendre des précautions...
Ca appelle des précautions,
de venir sur un plateau de télé.
On sait que c'est pas l'endroit...
propice, favorable :
c'est pas normalement ici
que ça se passe,
mais dans les histoires
de révolution,
parce qu'il s'agit
d'une révolution des mentalités,
il faut parler
au plus grand nombre.
Quand vous voyez 2-3 personnes
dans les cours d'assises,
qu'on supprime les jurés,
l'ouverture au public,
il faut parler aux gens.
Il y a eu
un sondage dans Le Parisien
selon lequel
70 % des Français pensaient
que quand une femme
avait été violée,
elle n'avait pas voulu l'empêcher.
Il faut parler sur les plateaux,
avec des précautions.
-Certains jugent
que le délai de prescription,
loin de favoriser l'impunité,
peut être un déclencheur.
Vous considérez,
comme Elisabeth Badinter,
que 20-30 ans,
c'est suffisant ?
Elles doivent
"prendre leurs responsabilités" ?
-Ce terme est d'une violence inouïe.
Enfin...
On parle beaucoup
de mémoire traumatique,
du fait que
les souvenirs ont été enfuis,
et puis, ils reviennent.
-C'est contesté.
-Voilà...
Parfois...
-L'amnésie traumatique.
-C'est contesté, car d'un coup,
ce sont devenus des mots valises,
et qui fait que nous,
on lit des plaintes,
où les mots sont presque volés
aux plaignantes,
qui se raccrochent
à ces concepts.
Il a peut-être fallu ces mots
pour que certaines comprennent.
Ca fait pas longtemps
qu'on sait ce que c'est, un viol.
La définition du viol...
-Et répréhensible.
-Et pénalement répréhensible.
Il faut en parler
partout et comprendre
qu'on peut mettre des années.
Les femmes sont mieux accueillies
dans les commissariats.
On peut déposer plainte
six mois après...
-Porter plainte
30 ou 40 ans après,
c'est pas le risque
de l'arbitraire ?
-C'est prendre, de toute façon,
le risque d'une impunité,
c'est le risque
de l'impossibilité de la justice.
Je crois que c'est
pour cette raison-là aussi que...
l'imprescriptibilité n'aurait pas
de sens pour personne, mais...
mais aussi,
pour celui qui est accusé.
Tout le monde peut l'entendre,
qu'en termes de devoir citoyen,
même pour quelqu'un
qui a été fracassé par un crime,
enfin, peut-être qu'il faut pas
demander aux gens fracassés...
Ils sont pas juges,
témoins ou législateurs.
Quand on est victime,
on peut pas demander de...
d'avoir cette considération
pour le citoyen,
qui est que 30 ans après un crime,
les gens changent.
On peut pas être avocat sans penser
que les gens changent,
se réhabilitent.
C'est l'esprit de la loi.
Ensuite, la justice n'a plus de sens
lorsqu'elle passe des années après.
-Ca a du sens
de poursuivre quelqu'un
comme PPDA,
30 ans après les faits ?
-On est pas à 30 ans
pour toutes.
Toutes ne sont pas prescrites.
On est sur une série d'impunité
pour les plaignantes
que j'assiste,
et qui sont prescrites.
Les choses sont dites.
Il n'y a pas
de poursuite judiciaire.
Je suis pas là pour dire
si ça a du sens.
Que les choses soient dites,
ça a sérieusement du sens.
-Les victimes jugent souvent
que le lynchage médiatique
ou ces condamnations sociales
sans cadre sont légitimes,
faute d'une justice performante
et efficiente.
-Je sais pas si c'est légitime,
faute de, mais en tout cas,
si la justice était performante,
on n'aurait pas besoin de ça.
-De l'interpellation publique ?
-Oui.
Et c'est sûr que ça arrive
dans certains dossiers,
de voir que la justice avance pas,
que si les plaignantes
ou plaignants, parfois des hommes,
sont victimes, plus rarement,
de violences sexuelles.
D'après moi, ils le disent moins.
C'est une libération qui pourrait
venir les toucher aussi.
Vous déposez une plainte,
vous êtes mieux reçu,
et on vous dit :
"Rappelez-moi dans 18 mois,
je pourrai commencer l'enquête."
Et là, bien sûr
que si vous appelez
Mediapart, Le Monde ou Le Parisien,
l'enquête est faite plus rapidement.
Et là, les services de police,
peut-être un peu,
vont sentir le reproche, la honte,
se mobilisent.
Ca devrait pas
se passer comme ça.
-Vous le disiez, vous défendez
des victimes, comme des coupables.
Vous défendez Jacques Bouthier,
l'ex-PDG d'Assu 2000,
incarcéré pour viols
et agressions sexuelles.
Quelle différence
entre le traitement
de l'affaire
et la mise au pilori d'un PPDA ?
L'un est mis en examen, l'autre pas,
mais tous deux
sont présumés innocents,
jusqu'à preuve du contraire.
-Médiatiquement, c'est vrai que
la présomption d'innocence...
-Elle est bafouée,
dans les deux affaires.
-Pas que la présomption d'innocence,
le secret de l'instruction.
Il sort de chez le juge,
dans la presse,
on lit ce qui a été dit.
Ce qui, en réalité,
met les gens en danger,
met les enquêtes en danger,
sur les affaires en cours, moi,
j'appelle vraiment
à de la vigilance.
Sur les affaires prescrites,
je comprends
que ça offusque des confrères.
Si Hervé Temime était ici, il dirait
que je dis n'importe quoi,
mais je pense
que la libération de la parole,
sur les plateaux médiatiques,
est plus saine parce que justement,
ça ne se passe pas
sur un terrain judiciaire.
-Ca vaut comme
une condamnation sociale.
Parler dans les médias,
c'est un appel au lynchage,
avec les réseaux sociaux, de fait.
-Il faudrait légiférer un peu plus
sur les réseaux sociaux,
parce que je crois pas
qu'on puisse se dire
"On se muselle,
parce qu'il va y avoir un lynchage."
C'est prendre un risque.
Hélène Devynck, le jour où il y a eu
les bonnes feuilles publiées
dans Le Monde,
- c'est pas n'importe quel site -
a dû fermer,
parce qu'il y avait, justement,
un lynchage,
alors qu'elle-même,
elle est juste victime.
-Un lynchage à l'encontre
des victimes,
et à l'encontre des mis en cause.
-Oui, bien sûr.
Tout devient
d'une violence inouïe.
C'est pas ça
qui va nous faire taire.
-Faut-il interdire
de révéler l'identité d'une personne
accusée de délit sexuel
avant mise en examen ?
-Alors ça...
Rires
C'est pas une question
que je me suis posée.
Je me pose pas forcément
la question de la législation.
-Vous seriez pour ?
-Pourquoi pas.
Je peux pas vous répondre,
là, comme ça.
Réinvitez-moi !
Je vais répondre à ça.
Je comprends bien, moi, que...
C'est sûr,
les gens peuvent pas répondre.
Il faut quand même être honnête,
quand je vous dis je pense normal
qu'on puisse non pas accuser,
mais donner son récit,
quand on est victime,
il faut savoir qu'en face,
ils peuvent pas répondre.
En cela,
il faut appeler à la mesure.
C'est le travail de tout le monde.
-Dans son récit,
"Impunité",
Hélène Devynck dénonce l'immunité,
si j'ose dire, de PPDA,
l'inaction de TF1,
la machinerie qui a poussé
les victimes à se taire.
L'affaire est-elle
une guerre de récit,
avec la mise en cause
d'un système et d'un milieu ?
-La justice,
c'est le récit.
C'est vraiment...
Ca n'a rien à voir
avec la vérité.
D'ailleurs, ça s'appelle
la vérité judiciaire,
comme on a la vérité historique,
la vérité scientifique.
PPDA,
c'est pas que l'histoire de viols,
au pluriel,
c'est effectivement,
- je pense que le titre
est magnifiquement trouvé -
l'histoire d'une impunité,
quand on sait qu'il a fait
une fausse interview, par exemple.
-De Fidel Castro.
-Il a continué de présenter
le journal de 20h derrière.
Il y a eu plagiat,
tout ça est reconnu,
on peut en parler,
sur un livre,
et il présente
des émissions littéraires...
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
de plus grave, journaliste,
que de truquer une interview ?
Quand on est écrivain, de plagier ?
Et donc,
ça pose la question de l'idole,
ça pose la question du mythe,
que je trouve formidable,
d'ailleurs, comme question,
et de pourquoi on ne déboule pas
toute cette machinerie,
qui vous empêche de parler ?
Et de cette banalisation aussi
d'une impunité,
qui fait que tout le monde
reste finalement bouche bée.
-PPDA a décidé de porter plainte
pour dénonciation calomnieuse.
Cette stratégie...
-C'est pas Jacqueline Laffont.
-Cette défense
a été perçue par les plaignantes
comme une mesure de représailles,
parce que défendre coûte cher.
Vous avez qualifié cette plainte
par un mot, un seul : une "claque".
-Oui, oui,
une claque, et puis, après...
Après, ça nous a fait rire.
C'est quelque chose
de très important dans la vie.
Une claque,
parce que c'est une inversion...
Une inversion de la violence.
En même temps, ça fait rire,
dire : "Allons-y, à ce procès
qu'on arrive pas à avoir,
"puisque nous sommes prescrites."
-C'est une opportunité
pour que la parole des accusatrices
et du mis en cause,
se déploie dans l'arène judiciaire ?
-On l'attend avec grand plaisir.
Je n'ai vu que des extraits
de cette plainte.
En cas de plainte contre vous,
vous le savez
quand vous êtes convoqué,
et les extraits que j'ai lus
sont savoureux.
J'ai su que l'adversaire n'était pas
l'avocate habituelle de PPDA,
parce que c'était insultant,
ce qui était écrit
dans les médias.
Hâte qu'on lise la plainte,
qu'on y réponde.
On l'attend de pied ferme.
-"La justice vous ignore,
on ignore la justice."
On se souvient tous de la charge
d'Adèle Haenel,
dans Mediapart.
Elle est loin
d'être la seule à penser
que la justice ne sert à rien,
sinon, dissuader de porter plainte.
Vous partagez ce constat ?
-Oui.
Moi, j'avais écrit
un article après,
qui avait été titré :
"Adèle Haenel,
trop bien pour la justice ?"
C'est vrai que c'est...
C'est une vraie question et...
Elle a bien fait,
parce qu'elle a été le déclencheur
de cette question-là, en disant :
"En fait,
"moi, si j'y vais,
je vais être mal reçue
"et puis, il va rien se passer."
Donc...
Je...
C'est une question.
Je sais pas
si j'irais déposer plainte.
J'encourage personne
à aller déposer plainte,
mais je décourage personne.
-Vous ne découragez personne ?
Parce que les statistiques
sont peu encourageantes ?
Plus de 70 % des plaintes
pour violences sexuelles
sont classées sans suite,
et seule une plainte pour viol
sur 10
aboutit à une condamnation.
Que faire pour inciter les victimes
à pousser la porte
d'un commissariat ?
-Alors, ce chiffre-là,
c'est une condamnation
à la cour d'assises,
ou au tribunal correctionnel ?
Je sais pas.
Bon, une sur 10,
c'est sûr que c'est...
-C'est peu.
-..c'est peu.
Moins on déposera de plaintes,
moins ça s'améliorera.
Après, ça, c'est pas un discours
qu'on peut tenir aux plaignantes.
C'est déjà violent,
ce qui vous arrive...
-Pourquoi vous n'encouragez pas
à porter plainte ?
-Parce que c'est très personnel.
Parce que vous avez déjà
été dépossédée...
de quelque chose, d'une intimité,
de quelque chose d'inouï.
Vous avez déjà eu
une effraction terrible.
J'incite pas
à la deuxième violence, en fait.
Sur un devoir citoyen,
en face de quelqu'un,
j'ai envie de dire :
"Il faut y aller.
"On va améliorer les choses,
porter le discours."
On peut vouloir se taire,
penser que sa reconstruction
passe par autre chose...
-Que l'arène judiciaire.
Pour mieux prendre en compte
les plaignantes,
ne devrait-on pas
clarifier la notion
de consentement, la redéfinir,
la repenser dans le droit ?
Espagne, Canada et Suède
l'ont fait.
Irène Théry a proposé l'entrée
dans le droit
la notion de crédit de véracité,
qui permet aux dénonciateurs
de violences sexuelles
ne plus être soupçonnés de mentir,
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ?
-J'adore Irène Théry.
Rires
Mais en fait,
je suis pas d'accord.
-Pourquoi ?
-Le viol, c'est...
un acte de pénétration sexuelle,
avec menace, violence, contrainte,
ou surprise.
Et en fait,
ça fait peser la charge
uniquement sur l'acte,
et pas sur la victime,
qui n'a pas à dire :
"J'étais consentante."
C'est un dévoiement,
à mon sens,
de la loi,
que de parler de consentement.
Plus on va parler
de consentement,
plus ça va peser sur la plaignante,
le fait d'avoir dit
"Vous aviez dit
que vous étiez pas d'accord."
Elle n'a pas à le dire.
-Vous portez plainte
parce qu'on a volé votre sac,
personne ne met votre parole
en doute.
Pour viol...
-C'est une vraie question.
Je suis d'accord.
La loi, normalement,
ne doit pas se poser la question
du côté de la victime.
Elle est géniale,
cette question.
Pourquoi, sur le crime de viol,
qui concerne les femmes,
on regarde les victimes,
et sur les autres crimes,
on regarde l'auteur ?
-C'est une vraie question.
-Faire entrer le consentement
dans la loi, c'est faire entrer
la possibilité de cette question.
En ce moment, on demande s'il y a eu
une situation de contrainte.
Avec PPDA,
la contrainte hiérarchique,
par exemple,
elle peut y être sacrément.
La contrainte avec la différence
de l'âge, la surprise,
sur les stratagèmes et la violence,
n'en parlons pas...
"Il suffit", bien sûr,
c'est extrêmement compliqué,
d'aller caractériser
ces motifs-là,
et non pas le consentement,
qui est intrinsèque.
"Est-ce que j'étais d'accord ?",
personne ne peut apporter la preuve.
-Vous croyez
qu'il y a un malentendu
sur la justice ? Son rôle ?
Les victimes attendent d'elle
qu'elle les répare,
mais c'est pas son rôle.
-C'est pas son rôle.
-Vous l'expliquez aux plaignantes ?
-Je passe mon temps
à expliquer ça,
et j'en veux un peu aux confrères,
quand ils le font pas,
ou aux intervenants,
quand ils le font pas.
On peut avoir envie
de faire plaisir et dire :
"La justice va vous apporter
telle chose."
C'est une pierre, certainement,
mais pas une pierre
pour tout le monde.
On voit aussi des scènes judiciaires
qui sont magnifiques,
qui font que pour les jours
où on est découragé,
il y a ces jours,
ces moments,
où "Merci, maître.
Ca a été vraiment un moment...
"..un moment-clé et essentiel,
mais pas que."
-Dans "Porter leur voix",
merveilleux,
vous racontiez le quotidien
au parloir des prisons,
dans les prétoires,
à votre cabinet, des histoires
de coupables, humaines.
Dès la première phrase,
"Il en va du palais de justice
de Paris comme de certains hommes :
"l'extérieur est splendide,
l'intérieur est pourri."
Le ton est donné !
Rires
-Mais oui...
C'est violent.
-Pour le moins !
-La justice est violente,
mais disons-le,
disons-le d'entrée,
et il y a un rapport aussi
de violence extrême,
entre les avocats
et les magistrats,
ceux qui...
jugent et défendent,
ceux qui accusent et défendent.
Il y a des places qu'on aurait
choisies pour rien au monde,
des places auxquelles
on se sent bien, on est assigné.
Il y a des hommes
dont on peut se dire
qu'il y a quelque chose de pourri
au royaume du Danemark,
comme disent certains.
Mais il y a la lumière
que vous placez à un autre endroit.
Nous, on ment pas,
on parle de ces endroits-là.
-Merci, Laure Heinich.
-Merci, Daphné Roulier.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...